a gente gera ideia o tempo todo todo o
tempo a eu tenho 10 poucas idéias outras
pessoas geram muitas idéias mais
interessante de tudo isso é que as
idéias estão enclausurados na gente a
gente às vezes não consegue colocar ela
pra frente pra ser executada e muitas
vezes acontece que a gente não tem nem a
ideia para colocar em prática um erro -
ter resultado com ela isso acontece
muito isso acontece comigo eu por
exemplo sou palestrante comentou de
vendas
o empresário só estar tappero agora está
peru eu tenho dos estatutos
eu sou pai eu sou filhos ou irmãos o
atleta eu a gente vive no tiff funções e
todas elas geram idéias e muitas vezes a
gente consegue completar suas idéias
isso é frustrante gente muito chateado
então como é que vai transformar isso em
uma máquina de resultados porque a gente
possa continuar nossa vida de uma forma
mais motivada
mas feliz e fazendo bem para as pessoas
que estão ao nosso redor
olha que interessante como é que a gente
primeiro tem as ideias eu
particularmente em tomando banho aparece
idéias correndo comendo fazendo
exercício bugando conversando com as
pessoas o tempo todo a gente gera idéia
do que acontece que a gente faz com essa
idéia tem gente que escreve um papel de
colo pois tite tem gente que agora tem
aplicativo de notas bacana eu
particularmente manda um email pra mim
mesmo eu mandar e mail pra vocês mesmos
eu mando lá quem é mais importante que
você mesmo nessa vida eu mando locais na
caixa de entrada lá marcelo baratella ou
passou eu parei
vai ser o meu chefe no meu amigo da
minha mulher não eu abro meu e meio e
com as minhas ideias
eu tenho que valorizar primeiro que eu
tenho na minha cabeça então assim você
tem que criar os seus métodos seus
hábitos para as coisas andarem
efetivamente fazer as coisas acontecer
só que chegou um momento que a gente não
consegue mais fazer isso mais frustrante
porque são muitas idéias só se ter uma
idéia do que acontece hoje no mundo esse
é um dado global esse dado que eu peguei
no vale do silício que fui pro vale do
silício que 30 dias
enclausurado no vale do silício
entendendo a mentalidade de inovação que
o mundo está oferecendo pra gente
a informação foi a seguinte 90% do que
está na internet hoje foi criado nos
últimos 12 meses
é assustador você pensar nisso porque é
isso vai mostrar que está desencadeando
tudo tudo tem na internet você fica
pensando como eu vou sair disso e eu
posso dizer a vocês que eu tenho uma
história de superação que fez com que eu
criasse um método uma metodologia para
que as coisas acelerassem foi até que eu
comecei a ser um acelerador de
resultados e tudo aconteceu há 10 anos
atrás quando estava com o colesterol
altíssimo eram colesterol genético é
para quem entende de número de
colesterol etapa com 290 de colesterol e
o ideal é que tivesse com menos de 190
então tá com problemas eu tava morrendo
aos poucos essa é a verdade eu fui o meu
cardiologista cheguei lá meu
cardiologista lauro matar em nome de
morte
eu cheguei para ele fazer o doutor que
está acontecendo qual é o diagnóstico e
falou que está morrendo aos poucos foi
nossa
preocupado ele disse assim inclusive
conversando com você você disse que
gostaria de ter filhos mas sim em 22
meninos eu puder ter dois meninos
aliás eu tenho dois meninos hoje
vittorio felipe e ele falou assim para
mim você não vai ver seus filhos eu
falei nossa
na verdade aquele aquele médico
cardiologista me fazendo bem ele estava
vendendo a dor
aliás todo mundo vendedor vendedor
vendedor e 90 solução se entrega a
solução
olha que interessante isso que ele
estimulou que ele me aquilo me fez
contra uma dor muito forte dentro de mim
eu não quero morrer
e foi o que eu tenho que fazer e falou é
simples vai fazer exercício físico
regularmente e se alimente melhor todo
santo dia 9 falou aquela palavra todo
santo dia eu falei hashtag todos os
pratos do dia coloquei aquilo pra minha
vida eu falei tudo que eu fizer todo
santo dia um pouquinho vai chegar mais
perto de onde eu quero eu comecei a
adotar algumas práticas todo santo dia
mas pra eu poder fazer exercício e é uma
pessoa extremamente acidentada que
odiava caminhar
pediu pra caminhar eu fui caminhar
cheguei numa avenida na necessidade de
uma senhorinha ela era gordinha ela deve
ter uns 70 anos mas ela era um
espetáculo aquela pessoa
bom dia acelerar o ritmo tempo eu tentei
andar com ela não conseguia passar mal
eu comecei com vergonha eo meu médico
também ele falou assim você tem que
contratar um personal trainer foi
personal trainer é coisa de gente rica
é coisa de gente fresca eu não preciso
disso que você precisa é personal
trainer pra você é gente que está
morrendo aos poucos fui lá e contrata um
personal e era aquele cara animado 5
horas da manhã saúde é o que interessa o
resto não tem pressa vamos pra cima eu e
meu deus que eu arrumei vão passar a
rainha e agora esse objetivo e nós fomos
eu comecei a entender que não ia ser tão
fácil assim
e aí ele falou assim eu estou com
vergonha de você também o eleitor você
começa a correr marcelo pára de andar já
te escrevi uma prova de cinco
quilômetros
alguém já ocorreu a 5 quilômetros aqui
então pasmem
eu fiz a prova de 5 km 56 minutos
é uma vergonha a quem sabe é ridícula
praticamente andando chorando quando ele
estourado e ela estava lá a venha eu
chegava a ela no meio da multidão
fiquei com vergonha de mim mesmo
quando terminei a prova eu falei eu
dizia se foi ou não vamos pro 10
não consigo mais cinco têm que ter
consistência à execução a partir de
agora vai ser consistente vai fazer tudo
o que tem que ser feito da maneira que
tem que ser feito todo santo dia
montamos um treinamento eu fui seguindo
à risca aquilo
sabe quanto eu fiz a prova de 100 57
minutos
uol o que eu fiz o dobro da prova eu
consegui fazer praticamente o mesmo
tempo que no meio do pelotão e passei é
o mais legal foi conquistei o território
porque agora vou para 21 quilômetros ou
se vai mesmo já tinha escrevi sério era
uma prova plana era muito frio
foi em são paulo eu fiz a prova em uma
hora e 32
entrei no meio do pelotão que não era de
elite ainda mas eu comecei a ficar
animado eu falei agora eu posso
o resultado veio e me motivei fique
pronto para fazer a ação me motiva entre
a ação
e aí foi assim ok já sei qual é o
próximo desafio uma moratória e falou em
berlim em setembro mas você vai pagar em
euro e vai tirar férias com a sua mulher
que é bem merecido qual eu fiz a prova
foi a berlim em 4 horas e 4 minutos não
conseguir baixar os quatro minutos que
um pouco frustrado joelho inchado mas eu
vi que podia mais
mas não tinha mais para onde ele for sim
você já ouviu falar de triathlon
foi meu deus bom gente a história
seguinte né
depois que a sua idéia assim com essa
cara feliz e você tá com o resultado
assim com essa cara
chateada a única opção que tem a seguir
à risca a hashtag todo santo dia eu
falei agora vai ser para valer
foi quando eu fui me enveredar o mundo
disse nessa prova que era uma prova
muito interessante que é em um esporte
com três modalidades
foi assim que ele me ensinou e aí eu fui
e tive a oportunidade da minha vida de
tirar sua foto
essa foto é uma foto que eu tenho eu
guardo com muito carinho que representa
muito pra mim é uma prova de término do
irã o mesmo que eu fiz que foi
praticamente ficar 11 horas correndo
pedalando e nadando
eu tenho até sal no corpo se podem
perceber que tanto esforço que eu fiz eu
passei no pórtico de chegada com meu
filho aquele que o médico falou que não
ia ter aquele que ele falou que não ia
ver e quando através do choro muito eu
agradeço muito e eu sou desclassificado
da prova porque tinha uma cláusula
dizendo assim versículo 8 capítulo 9 não
pode atravessar o pórtico com familiar
desculpa os orientadores da prova estão
vendo agora é tudo na minha pra isso que
essa foto ninguém tem e todos os dias da
minha vida e olha essa medalha e falou
ao o que eu consegui fazer quando eu
estava com 290 e agora tô com 120 de
colesterol
está tudo entupido e agora é seguir em
frente para continuar
gente essa magia acontece quando você
cria uma metodologia tem um negócio de
uma funil do conhecimento dá uma olhada
para isso é interessante um cara que
escreveu isso roger martin escreveu um
livro chama design de negócios
tudo o que for fazer na sua vida a
partir de agora ver se é assim eu tenho
uma ideia aí tudo no mistério profundo
eu não sei como eu consegui o resultado
daquilo eu vou montar uma palestra eu
não sei como fazer
não sei como organizar você encontra
pessoas que vão te dar em sites que vão
te dar sacadas que vou mostrar para você
alguns caminhos e aí você tem a eureka é
o momento de heurística momento onde as
bolinhas começam a se conectar e começa
a criar afinidade com a idéia e começou
a confiar mais naquilo
senão o sabotador que destrói a ideia
que aquele que fala assim ó você não vai
ter tempo você não tem recurso
você não tem competência para fazer isso
nós vamos nos autos sabotando todo dia
todo momento mas a heurística deixa a
gente mais feliz só está faltando o
seguinte como é que eu faço não sabe
como que eu faço eu tenho que criar um
algoritmo do meu negócio é quando se
fala de algoritmo do total de matemática
estão falando de programação de
computador
mais do que isso nós estamos falando do
jeito que eu enxergo algoritmo algo que
te dá ritmo algoritmo é isso é uma coisa
que vai te dar ritmo pode ver que as
pessoas de sucesso elas têm ritmo
freqüência e quantidade de vezes nas
atividades guarda isso freqüência e
ative e quantidade de vezes que você faz
uma atividade vão te levar consequência
que o resultado resultado é conseqüência
seja ouviram isso
as causas vão levar vocês os resultados
acreditem isso o treino me levou a
completar um ano
e aí você sim depois o algoritmo
resolvido você começa a ter o código do
sucesso eu sei como fazer
agora eu tenho que inovar e melhorar e
inovar a gente é uma coisa muito bonita
de se falar e muito simples de se fazer
é você pegar o que já tem melhorar e
gerar valor para o usuário ou pra você
pega o que já tem
melhora e gera valor se não gerar valor
você não inovou
isso faz sentido pra vocês chacoalha o
dedo todo mundo faz sentido mas se
continuar chovendo que não fez não faz
sentido
e aí você vai para o sucesso que é a
acreditar porque pra acreditar
você tem que passar pelo conhecimento o
conhecimento quanto mais conhecimento e
tem mais a meta você bate disse não faz
sentido se eu creio eu pratico eu repito
aquilo exaustivamente para subir neste
palco eu repetir esta palestra pelo
menos cinco vezes
olhando no espelho andando do carro
vindo do avião e antes de entrar aqui
porque eu tenho que entregar o meu
melhor
então se eu acredito que eu posso eu
pratico e repito isso exaustivamente que
praticar faz a gente levar o erro e um
erro de impressão de consertar rápido
com certo erro rápido prático
exaustivamente até você entender que ia
chegando perto da perfeição
e aí sim você começa a ter resultado é a
analogia de um menino andando de
bicicleta onde o seguro ele e falo vai
meu filho tirou as duas rodinhas e solta
em vez de tirar uma primeiro já tinha as
duas que ele vai cair
ele vai perder a confiança em você mas
ele vai ganhando isso ao um tempo que
ele vai repetindo aquilo e isso vai te
levar o sucesso
essa é uma foto minha quando eu fiz uma
palestra para 10 mil pessoas 10 mil
pessoas gente é muita gente e não parava
gente chegar o dia que o time nesse
palco e quem tirou a foto para minha
mulher que eu nem sabia que ela tinha
essa foto
eu lhe falei assim caramba eu era
professor
o dia que eu falei vou me tornar
palestrante era um caminho árduo e logo
a ser seguido que eu faço isso há 15
anos e todos os dias que olha e fala
assim parece simples mas não é mais a
forma que eu fiz foi simples executando
todo dia eu estava a ser feito para
chegar nesse dia então se você tá agora
pensando você tem uma idéia é não pode
ser feita
o que você não tem conhecimento
suficiente de como chegar então vai
buscar conhecimento de como chegar e
crie a crença a prática repetição para
chegar ao resultado
acredite nisso agora já pensa agora onde
você tiver e coloca aquela ideia que é
pessoal profissional social de guardar
dinheiro e fazer exercícios seja o que
for que você pode porque senão você vai
ver alguém que é o seu vizinho fazendo e
fala como é que ele conseguiu
e aí você fala podia ter sido eu
então para eu fechar essa palestra vocês
entregando o conteúdo excepcional eu
queria deixar algumas mensagens pra você
que é a seguinte a primeira delas
as idéias são feitas para nascerem na
sua cabeça e não pra ficar empresas
a primeira coisa que eu queria falar pra
vocês
a segunda bateria metas é possível e é
uma questão de escolha
se você escolher você vai conseguir
basta criar o seu método ea terceira é
uma frase que eu gosto muito de um amigo
meu que uma frase simples mas que faz
todo sentido
essa frase diz o seguinte o menino que
não anda não vende picolé
essa frase é legal para quem mora no
interior do brasil vai entender bem
aquele aquelas pessoas simples que estão
lá com seu carrinho de picolé
eu conheci um em goiânia vem de 300
picolés por dia já formou três filhos um
médico advogado engenheiro e o que ele
faz todo dia faz o que tem que ser feito
e ele acredita naquilo então na tua vida
nada vai ser de graça se você não te
trabalho árduo muitas horas de trabalho
acordar muito cedo dormir muito tarde
mas sabendo para onde você tem que essa
é a mensagem que queria deixar para
vocês ea última
sem dúvida nenhuma é essa a única coisa
que você pode fazer é a sua parte
muito obrigado